the case against kyle rittenhouse the
teenager who shot leftist rioters that
had been threatening him during the blm
attacks last summer has been gradually
collapsing since the trial
began and yesterday one of the leftists
who was actually shot by rittenhouse
may have put the final nail in the
case's coffin
it wasn't until you pointed your gun at
him
advanced on him with your gun now your
hands down pointed at him
and he fired right
correct oh [ __ ] that's it
that's it
directed verdict on all the murder
charges kyle knows
directed verdict on the murder charges
he just he just exhaled
kyle oh he looks like he's gonna cry
how do you not
how do you
how do you not acquit after that
look
you know testimony is not going the way
the state wanted when one of the
prosecuting attorneys ends the
questioning with his head in his hands
kyle rittenhouse was obviously acting in
self-defense given what we heard
yesterday not only should he not be
convicted he shouldn't even have been
charged
but rittenhouse's crime has nothing to
do with guns or homicide
if he had different colored skin or
different political views
the elite in this country would be
calling for him to walk
written house is real crime oh it's one
of the worst crimes of all it's being a
right-wing white guy the new york times
is
lying about what happened yesterday at
the trial by the way just so you know if
you're reading cnn or the new york times
or whatever there was a tweet that went
out from julie bozeman from the new york
times says quote gross croots he was the
the guy testifying he was the guy who
had been shot by kyle rittenhouse gross
croots a paramedic from west allis and
milwaukee suburb was shot in the arm by
rittenhouse gross croots was holding a
handgun pointed in the air when
rittenhouse shot him from a short
distance away uh julie bosman from the
new york times sent out that tweet
after
yesterday's testimony
so after she knew it was bogus
she sends out that tweet
then uh
this guy testifies and says no he i was
pointing the gun at him and that's the
only time he shot eventually she deleted
the tweet but the media are really
really desperate to portray kyle
rittenhouse's a
white supremacist
right-wing white suprema no he was a guy
acting in self-defense while blm and
antifa burned down not just his city but
the country and why were they rioting
they were rioting because police rightly
shot someone named jacob blake who had
just sexually assaulted a woman was
driving off with her kids but the media
and the left took his side jacob blake's
side because they're anti-cop because
white people bad black people good
because right winger is bad left winger
is good because cops bad criminals good
because because they have a narrative in
mind that they're going to push
and kyle rittenhouse fit the narrative
of the bad guy and the problem is the
facts on the ground completely
contradict their narrative because kyle
written house from everything we know
about this case was acting in
self-defense they should call it call it
a day now the prosecuting attorney
should just walk off the job say you
know what
sorry we tried see you and let
rittenhouse off the hook did you like
that clip i'm glad you did if you liked
it please leave a comment below ring the
bell subscribe but if you really want to
get the notifications where big tech
people are not going to stop you from
getting notifications i recommend you go
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]